this ear biscuit is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes it fast and easy to create your
own professional website or online
portfolio for a free trial and 10% off
your first purchase go to
squarespace.com and use our offer code
R&L ra and dl now Squarespace is well
known for being incredibly easy to use I
mean that's kind of the whole point it
makes a great looking website but it's
incredibly easy to use you don't have to
know HTML you don't know all this stuff
you just go on there you know I don't
even even know what HTML I don't want to
know what it says I didn't know it
existed but it could be the case that at
some point during the process you do
need some help you do need to need some
support they have a customer to customer
care team that's available 24 hours a
day seven days a week if you didn't know
link that's every single hour in the
week like that hour there's a player
one guy no this is a hundred people no
it's one guy who just never sleeps he
has the gift his name is Ralph okay
maybe that's Ralph yeah no I think this
is a hundred people who work for
Squarespace and in any given time some
of them are there to answer your
questions and I gotta be honest with you
this is important to me because I just
this week not kidding you had an issue
with support with a service that I use
with Squarespace
no not with Squarespace with this
another service that I use well then why
what other service
it was the service that I used to pay my
homeowners dues so why are you calling
Squarespace I wasn't calling Squarespace
I was calling this other service that
takes care of my homeowners dues and
they weren't there because they were
like we're sorry the customer care team
is sleeping now Jarek you know that's
how I felt when I heard the voicemail
they were like we're near a Ralph's no
that's not gonna happen with Squarespace
they're going to be there when you call
in that you know that's good because you
know when you're building a website
sometimes you just need to talk to
somebody
true hey what does HTML stand for I know
I don't have to know I don't know I'm
just asking you know but you can't start
a free trial with no credit card
required and start building your website
today but when you do just decide to
sign up we think you will make sure you
use the offer code R&L that's our aandl
you'll get 10% off your first purchase
and it's a really good way to support
your biscuits and do not you
their helpline as a dating service or
for audio companionship use us for that
here at ear biscuits let's make another
one
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet or not what well I
mean that don't sell us that short I
mean to what I was gonna say it this
week that interesting person is you link
oh and you rhett and me us okay guys
here's what we're gonna do we're just
going to interview each other
that's what Rhett and I have decided
we're gonna interview each other this is
an experimental fresh out out of the out
of the box thinking type of ear biscuit
here hopefully I that this is gonna be a
wild ride of in-depth conversation
between the two of us right okay so
involving some Twitter questions as well
yeah I think the thing that we have
discovered about ear biscuits is that
it's been fascinating getting to know
all the people that we've talked to and
we just have a feeling that because
there is or are two of us there is two
of us there is two of us we are going to
take advantage of the fact that there is
two of us and we're going to talk to
each other because I'm kind of operating
on the premise that we know each other
incredibly well and we have discussed a
lot together we've also incidentally
discussed a lot on the Internet people
know a lot about our lives but you but I
still believe there is quite a bit that
I don't know about you and that you
don't know about me and other things
that need to be rehashed and I don't
mean like let's go back and you know
open up old wounds or maybe I don't know
maybe that will happen dig up the buried
hatchet no I don't think that will
happen but maybe you're saying that is
there a challenge here that we'll see if
we can learn something new about each
other while the audience members out
there that's where I think learn about
us and the
intimacy is a virus that's the way
they're working the magic is gonna
happen I'm not kidding because yeah we
thought about okay well we were we
wanted to do a semi-regular episode of
your biscuits where we talk to each
other so I will say at the beginning
depending on how this goes how we feel
about it how you feel about it we're
going to do it again
if everyone agrees that this is
something worth doing so you can let us
know yeah let us know on Twitter hashtag
your biscuits but we're not changing the
course of your biscuits I know don't
know do want to clarify have a lot of
amazing guests lined up and that's gonna
keep happening on that will be the vast
majority of what your business is all
about right so every now and again we
just want to if if this is something fun
is something that works for everybody
maybe we'll bring it back so once a
month or ever so often I don't know
we're not committing but and the last
thing I'll say before we dive in is
starting to interview each other is you
just yawned I'm just gonna pull a
glozell on your on your honor I'm
already bored with you what is that what
that don't do that
it hasn't been that long of a day I love
my job I love what I do
and one of the I mean it's a privilege
to be able to just dream up things and
do it and have you listen to us and
enjoy hanging out with us I mean I'm
sincerely thankful for that one of my
favorite parts of the job that I think
is highlighted here in this exercise
here is we get to try new things it's
you know the analogy of just throwing
stuff at the wall and seeing what sticks
and I think this is just another example
of that it's energizing from a creative
standpoint to try new things and just to
see what happens I mean that that's the
key to success and maintaining relevance
in in the world of entertainment anyway
I mean for us to be as successful as
they have been and I feel like it's
trying to keep your head above water and
maintain relevance and you just have to
try new things and see what so what
works so that's exciting to me it's
energizing doing the same thing I'm not
doing it old I'm not doing this to be
successful like I'm doing this because I
care about you
and what did it sound like I was saying
doing it to be successful no I mean no I
mean people might think that what I'm
what I'm trying to say it's a creative
endeavor to try trying to innovate what
were trying to innovate and I'm just
saying that I originally we were like
well let's do let's do in your biscuit
where we just talk to each other.if
first I was like let's just shoot the
breeze you know let's just do when we
talk and see what the conversation goes
but then it hit us it's like no the tone
of this show is inquisitive right
it isn't just two guys building on
ridiculous ideas like we do every day on
good mythical morning
it's inquisitive it's like there's
things that impersonal it's personal and
it's an inquisitive and that's what
we're going to do so what we have done
is we wanted to when we do a show like
this a special edition of a rhettandlink
only air biscuit we want to make it
themed so we decided that let's just
talk about childhood okay now we've done
this thing where we talk about people's
childhood in their career and all this
stuff maybe we'll get to all those
things with us but we wanted to start
with childhood so we've come up with
some questions for one another but we
also prompted our Twitter followers link
did this and I did this earlier we said
hey do you have any questions for the
other that you want us to ask one
another and so we have a collection of
questions that we've come up with and a
question a collection of questions that
you have come up with and we're just
gonna go back and forth and see where
this goes yeah that's us we've never
interviewed each other I've asked you
questions
yeah I've asked in life I've been like
where you won't go for lunch
yeah kind of questions that you did that
today and we went to that place I got
huevos rancheros as we were very good we
went to that place I still taste it okay
um is that your first question
no because lunch is over it's can you
still taste what you ate for lunch
see I can I cannot I think this is a
good place to start we're gonna I mean
this is not my question this is from Bob
Saget has swag on Twitter oh I thought
those Bob sage it has swag tell the
story of how you became Blood Brothers
not really a question but we'll go with
it anyway would you please tell us the
story what if I had it that it would be
polite okay so the story of us becoming
Blood Brothers I think we may have meant
in places but I don't know that we've
ever fully unpacked the true story of
the blood oath pact which it really
happened that we really made in high
school so it has been cataloged or
represented in our documentary that we
made years ago called looking for miss
Locklear where we kind of tell the story
about the blood oath that we made and in
the movie we reenact that and we always
we say we went back to the same place
no we talked about how we went to the
rock rock right right I don't know where
we talked about it we talked about
things all over the place but this is
gonna be the definitive place to tell
this story now right I really think it
starts with the cow pasture don't you I
mean that's the location of the blood
oath so I think that's the starting
point yeah so we grew up Buies Creek
North Carolina near a Country Club not
in the country club we weren't those
kinds of people so don't judge us we
were outside of the Country Club very
near to a place called Keith Hills so
this is a golf course yeah an 18-hole at
the time golf course and what hole was
it that was on the like the far edge of
the golf course hole 3 it was holding it
was hole number 6 oh it was hole number
6 which is now it's they changed the
back nine in the front nine so it's
whatever that would be it's the six hole
the back nine so I guess that would be
hole number 16 I've never played golf
I'm glad I'm honored that you're asking
me
hole number 15 so you're like asking me
math plus golf and my mind is mom it was
hole number six and I'm just telling you
this because it's the old number six and
if you have to be if you happen to live
in the area if you go down there and
it's a par four that goes up a hill and
then to the right there's a creek and
across the creek there is a cow pasture
that was constantly filled with cattle
and this was more attractive to us not
that we were attracted to cows I mean we
did grow up in Buies Creek but that's
not what I mean we were more attracted
to the cow pasture than we were to the
golf course especially link yeah that's
true so what we would do is we would
after school I mean we had to been like
sixteen years old because you would we
would drive our cars I know we would
ride our bikes we might have been 14 or
15 when we started doing this but we
would go out to the
no it was a middle we started in middle
school because Ben Greenwood was the one
who came up with the idea and we were
really active with Ben and all
throughout elementary school and
especially middle school so our favorite
hobby was to go across the golf course
across the stream into the cow pasture
and chased the cows it just a you just
called Buies Creek a stream just so you
know that was Buies Creek that was the
creek Oh Louise really you called it the
stream I didn't I did no I never knew
that I'm pertinent alright now I've
already learned something I didn't know
that was Buies Creek that was Buies
Creek Wow it ran behind my house and
then it kept going all the way through
Keith hills and them so nothing is more
exhilarating in the town of Buies Creek
than having a herd of cattle flee your
presence and it's just exhilarating to
do that until the farmer shows up and
chases you off but there was a pond
there that the cows would get in and
around the pond there were some rocks
one of which was a very big rock wood
then I'm talking it was probably a five
foot tall boulder it was big it was it
was obviously a rock that had been dug
up out of the ground you know those farm
ponds that are completely rectangular
and they have two hills of dirt on each
side of them because they just dug it
out with a big tractor so this big rock
comes out and a little rock beside it
and for some reason we and this is what
we talked about in an intro to the film
was we devised this plan where we would
just have these long drawn-out
conversations after we were when we were
resting from chasing the cows we would
sit down on the rock and we came up with
this system that whoever was sitting on
the big rock would have the floor to
talk and then the other person would sit
on the small rock and listen and can
only ask questions to keep the
conversation going we need that here on
ear biscuits it was very much bigger
chair and a littler chair it was very
much like in your biscuit wasn't it well
it was inhale like this and then after a
while we would you would have your time
and then you would trade spaces and the
person would sit on the big rock and
they would have the floor to dictate the
conversation and I want to be clear here
that our conversations I don't remember
a whole lot of details but that is what
we're gonna kind of talk about is what
we ended up talking about our
conversations were
probably if we were to go back and
listen to them now we would be we would
laugh at what we thought how we thought
the things that we said to each other
but we weren't just talking about what
it was like to be in middle school we
were talking about the future we was
always talked about the future we were
certainly talking about girls at times
we would talk about what she would
imagine that kids would talk about look
at that big cow what but we would talk
about that yeah what if what if that cow
could fly would you ride it you know
what if what if I don't know just stupid
very amateur middle school you know
philosophical questions but the thing
that strikes me is they were very
future-oriented as well yeah we would
talk about dreams what it was that we
wanted to do and I and I want to be
clear here that you know we grew up in
Buies Creek which was an amazing place
to grow up but it was not the kind of
place that you just naturally he didn't
think about careers in entertainment or
comedy you didn't know anybody who did
that kind of thing so there wasn't any
real sense that that was going to happen
but we decided one day that we started
talking more about we wanted to do
something just this big something that
we didn't know what it was but we wanted
to do it together right when we grew up
we wanted to yeah and first of all I'm
sure this whole future orientation is
something that knowing you and knowing
myself better now I can pretty much bet
that this that whole future Bend is
something that came from your mind cuz
you just were always that's how you
think whereas the whole system of who
was talking when and how we how we
talked you came up with it you could the
rules of analyzing questions I'm sure
that was probably my idea I can't
remember but just the way that our
brains work differently I could see how
that would come together but yeah we
would suck we would talk about what what
are we gonna do what are we gonna do
we're gonna and it wasn't we didn't talk
about entertainment at first I think we
did we certainly knew we liked to
entertain and show often and to
any audience that we could find but the
I but we can't but we had the idea to do
the blood oath without saying okay we're
definitely gonna be filmmakers it was
let's make a blood oath that we're gonna
we're gonna be teammates in creating
something we're gonna be like business
partners in whatever we do that like
yeah we're friends now but we we have a
sense that we're gonna we're gonna like
make something big I don't know what it
is but we should probably write it down
right well if you're gonna write it down
we should probably cut ourselves and
sign it in blood I mean and that's what
we did we took two sheets of paper out
there we wrote down we wrote something
that was I mean unfortunately I'll go
ahead and tell you we don't have these
sheets of paper anymore as sad as that
is in fact link is the one that wouldst
I lose everything or I used to lose
everything
you'd lose things more than now than I
do now but back in those days you
collected everything right oh you but
you don't have the paper but I can
attest you that it did exist at one
point and we wrote something that was
like we're gonna do something awesome
and we're gonna do that something
awesome together now let's cut ourselves
and do you remember how we cut ourselves
I think it was like a shard of glass
that was like laying and it was like it
was like a sharp piece of glass in the
dirt yeah yeah it was this is not
advised by the way and we cut our palms
yeah you should cut your if you're gonna
do a blood oath you should cut like
prick the end of your finger why well I
cut your freaking well obviously I've
established that we were misguided but
and I kept that thing in my wallet for
for like two and a half years yeah and
then I lost the whole wallet oh oh
that's what happened with you I lost the
whole wallet yeah yeah I just went home
and price it it down and then you know
my mom threw it away but it meant a lot
it meant that the idea I was definitely
committed to the idea yeah so that was
the question from Bob Saget has swag
that that's the story so I guess from
that point on it wasn't necessarily
something that we talked a lot about but
there was always this guiding principle
that was well it's in blood you know you
know we don't have to talk about all the
time you know there's kind of
yeah we've got it we've got to stay
committed to this amorphous idea mm-hmm
that we're going to do something
together something big the word big was
definitely in it now are you gonna ask
me a question now yeah yeah I go first
I'm going to yeah I'm gonna move there's
another question that I think is good
for the both of us to discuss kind of
like that but I want to move this into a
more one-on-one
noka place it's a little weird yeah this
is gonna be strange I like it though
now when we first met we met in first
grade I moved from North Carolina I mean
I moved from California to North
Carolina and I met you at the time you
were at Buies Creek Elementary School do
you think I forgot I'm just for the
benefit of everyone listening and we met
on that first day and you know there's a
movie about that but you were living
with your mom and your stepdads Immy and
the time right which was in Buies Creek
now Jimmy Capps before that where did
you live
I'm now I don't know this before you
moved in with Jimmy where'd you live my
mom and dad split up when I was 2 years
old
and where were they I don't remember I
was 2 they weren't I do remember well I
know I don't remember my dad was a
farmer at the time like a tobacco farmer
and Boone Trail which is like I mean you
know you'll eat between Lillington and
Sanford it was like nothing out there
except fields and you know some of those
were my dads and then a trail to whom
yeah so and there's um so that's where I
was born and so but I mean my first
memories are my mom got remarried to
Jimmy and they were front they were like
friends from like high school and yes so
they had known each other for years and
then they both went through a divorce
and then I think rebounded they both had
they were in the rebound marriage
together they're not together now when I
was 13 they got divorced but my first
memories are
in that house that where you met me with
Jimmy and my house and Buies Creek and
me his daughter so but where but your
mom okay so you were in Boone trail and
I remember I guess I remember the house
that I was like born in where my mom and
dad lived I'm pretty sure and then where
did your mom live my dad still lives
after the divorce from your dad I'll
explain why I'm asking this is um I
think that she moved into a trailer in
my in her parents like a next-door her
parents yeah in Andrew in Andrew I asked
I asked this because I've never thought
about this yeah it's this is pretty it's
kind of crazy to think about - I know
why I was in Buies Creek did you know
what I'm saying like I came to Buies
Creek because my dad got a job at
Campbell law school teaching law still
teaches law at Campbell law school until
this day and that's why we moved from
Thousand Oaks California to boy Street
North Carolina and I never really
thought about the fact that like you
were in Buies Creek because your mom
married a guy who lived in Buies Creek
yeah
Jimmy had a house and that was and I
just want to point out that that was
that was the seminal moment you know if
your mom had it been like you know let's
just stay here in Boone trailer I'm
gonna stay in Andrew or she had not had
a romantic connection with her former
high school classmate Jimmy Capps you
would have never been at Buies Creek
school because I always wonder I was
like what III didn't know why your mom
was in Buies Creek you know cuz it was a
a why Jimmy was there because all of my
family is in completely yes yeah yeah no
family I mean within 15 minutes and we
can thank Jimmy Capps for this there
would have been no blood oath if there
hadn't been a Jimmy Capps we should call
him right now
I don't have his number okay I mean I
remember the number that when I lived
there it's probably the same number okay
well I'll just put it out there and then
anyone can call it I want it do you
remember the number my first phone
number where we were friends this is a
really good question because can you
remember a phone no no but do you know
but I think this is something that
younger people today will not will not
and we knew everyone's phone number like
I remember Leslie people's phone number
my girlfriend first girls now there was
a speed dial but yeah you had to
basically know everybody's phone number
because he had to punch it in you
couldn't pull it up on some smart device
okay I'm gonna give you the number with
it we can bleep out okay nine one zero
mm-hmm
eight nine three no that's close though
pretty close I mean that's amazing I
have not dialed that I have not dialed
that number since wait what year for
like 25 years and I almost got it right
yeah yeah but I did get it right but if
you remember my phone number which is
still my that's easy
I'm not giving it's still your parents
phone number I don't want to have to
beep anything out it's too much work you
know that you know it though yeah I'll
definitely know it you want to call it
right now yeah I call all the time talk
to your mom okay we just we just we have
connection that's good me and Mama died
I would I would call Diane but it's
weird it's we your parents are still
together
it's it's weird having your first
memories and growing up in a house where
I know this guy's not my dad he's just a
stepdad who like I didn't have that much
of a connection with him it was like it
there was this feeling of well you're
not my real dad
you're just my step dad your mom mom's
husband so we're not gonna be that tight
you know he still spanked you though
but he'd hit me and he should have and
he needed to the times did he did he
probably should've done it more than
that but we weren't that close and it
was this thing of okay I have a sister
but she's not really my sister and I
don't like her and I don't like her even
more because I can't I have permission
to like her even less because she's not
a real sister and I don't have to really
love Jimmy I can just either like him or
not or tolerate him now that's kind of
what I grew up in and that was that's
all I knew but it was I mean I was
certainly envious when I go to your
house as a youngster and oh look at this
happy family there's two brothers who
real brothers and both the parents
actually lives there and they they drink
milk for dinner we did isn't that nice
it's like a lot of milk is why I'm six
foot seven and I remember thinking well
I'm going over to a house where there's
like an intact family like there was a
sense of you shoot you thought it you
thought about that yeah and I was like I
guess if your parents are still together
you drink milk for dinner well and you
know they're not hated milk it never
crossed my mind
I never thought like it I know I never
was like I wonder this is kids don't
think about this I think kids nowadays
think about this because they're more
like in tune with what everyone's
feeling because of the internet but my I
definitely did think about it I never
thought they I wonder how link feels
about this does the fact that you know I
have a dad and mom who live together how
does this affect him and I also did not
ask the probably the more important
question which was how does the fact
that he lives with a stepdad affect him
I mean we didn't even you don't even
think about that really nine years old
you don't have you don't have these type
of deep conversations matter of fact you
don't have them until you have an ear
biscuit without a guest well but you
know the sad thing and you know this
probably by the time when this your
biscuit comes out my parents will not be
in that house that is sad because I have
a lot of memories of you know being
jealous of your family now no I wouldn't
say i-i've it on my parents I don't
think that I was jealous but um em Kimmy
wasn't a bad guy I remember he built
that fort oh yeah for me and really for
us like you were pretty much the only
friend that came to my house and we
would walk out I went to a lot of
people's houses not to make you feel
nothing to make you feel bad I went to
your house more than anybody's but I was
addicted to spending the night at
people's houses I would they would I
would meet a new kid at school he would
be there a week and I would invite
myself to spend the night with him I
don't understand why I was just like hey
dude cusp in the night of your house can
I look in your refrigerator and see what
your family's like I think it's a I mean
it's a personality thing but also think
it may be a sense of security I was
absolutely terrified to stay at anybody
else's house I mean that one time that
we had that sleepover at Adam
Nicholson's house and he and he showed
us Texas Chainsaw Massacre yeah and then
afterward we walk
around in the dark in the woods and
pitch black and we're like in fifth
grade yeah like I was terrified man and
then I opened his refrigerator and it
wow there's a lot of food all over the
place in here it was scary
I was my refrigerator but it was was
very neat and very orderly and that made
me secure as secure as I could be but I
guess I was still I didn't have the
security of comfort of to be able to
leave home but we had that for it was
basically just you remember it was just
two trees I remember it with two two by
fours connecting between the two trees
like eight feet in the air
it was probably five feet in the air but
we just felt like it was really tall
what was the kind of four that you get
you get up there and then you sit there
and you're like well what do we do now
and then you get down right because it's
Jimmy made that it was awesome for be up
there for a few seconds okay I should
ask you a question should at this point
um did you or do you resent your dad no
oh
finish the question you finish the
question do you resent your dad for all
the basketball drills he made you do I I
really want to know how you feel about
that today I know we've talked about if
I did your dad was basically the the
impetus in both of us going to
engineering instead of going to film
school which by the time we were
graduated from high school that was the
application of the blood oath was let's
go to film school it at unc-asheville he
was like no you need to do something
sensible Rhett and I'm like why okay
I'll do that too but he wanted you to be
a basketball player in college and he
made you do all these drills like how
they were there was a span there when I
couldn't you're like oh don't come over
to hang out until I've done my drills so
I'd have to wait two hours mm-hmm how
much you were being groomed to be a
basketball star well for nothing you
hold that against your dad for nothing
that's my question whether that was a
statement for month for nothing
question mark you're not a basketball
player I was one heck of a basketball
player at one point
and I could still beat you well first
first before you give you atleast
categoric terrorised the amount of work
that you put into it and and how your
dad was involved yeah okay so you know I
was tall that's well-known fact I still
AM
I was athletic that's disputed at this
point but I was very athletic played all
kinds of sports and was successful at
them and loved them and was very
competitive still AM competitive but I
wanted to succeed I mean I had an older
brother three years older than me two
years older in age and three years in
school and we were very competitive we
played a lot of basketball we were very
athletic family my dad was very much
into sports and so we were too
so as soon as I was self-motivated it up
to a certain extent I was very
self-motivated eighth grade you know I
wanted to be the basketball star when we
got the high school all I could think
about was getting onto the JV team by
the end of my freshman year I've been
put on the varsity team to play in the
the state playoffs and I was in and I
just thought I mean it had definitely
been engrained in me that listen like
you can be a basketball star you can pay
for your college this way and you got to
understand that you know from a very
young age not only was i interested in
basketball but I was the ball boy one of
the ball boys for Campbell basketball I
remember how much I was in the Campbell
basketball yeah went to every single
game was the ball boy allowing my
brother and Brooks Lee and Michael Juby
and I wanted that really bad it was like
really important so when high school
rolls around and then it's just okay now
you've got to get good so that you can
get recruited and play college
basketball my dad my dad was not he was
he wasn't overbearing it was I mean he
has that kind of personality and people
see that he you go to a basketball game
with my dad's there he's gonna yell at
the ref he's gonna yell at the coach
he's gonna yell at me if I'm on the
court net I don't know what if something
about my personality I never it never
hit me until later in life that like
that should have been embarrassing hmm
like to have your dad yell at you to do
something differently from the stands in
high school in front of everyone like
most people would be embarrassed by that
but I was just like your pants off I was
looking at him and then the coach would
that coach gage would have to tell me he
was like don't listen to your dad listen
to me you know what I'm saying and I was
just like oh okay
you know so there was you didn't care I
didn't care I was embarrassed by it and
then he would be like you need to you
know you need to do these drills you
need to do the 300 shot drill so I would
do things where I would shoot 300 shots
a day how long does it take to shoot 300
shots I don't know I gave all I had ball
handling drills and first of all you
understand I was actually I wasn't very
naturally talented and did a lot of work
but I didn't do nearly as much work as
as a guy who actually ends up being a
great player does but then he got like
the strength shoes yeah so rat had a in
his front yard
he was basically at the end of a
dead-end street not really a cul-de-sac
but though you had your dad put a
basketball goal out there and then so
you would play on the street because it
was the end of the street but then I
remember coming over there one day and
under the basketball goal there were
three increasingly larger sized boxes
boxes made out of plywood oh yeah and
endeth and the solid painted burgundy
and the tallest one was four and a half
feet tall no it was big enough to four
for a white man like me to jump up onto
and I was like what's this and then he's
not well I it's my strength shoe boxes
and then you had these shoes it shoes
shoes that looked like the Starship
Enterprise turned upside down
yeah it was a shoe but then it had a
platform built off of the photo of the
balls of the feet but just the toe so
that your heel was suspended in air and
you were forced to only use the balls of
your feet to run around yeah sounds like
a torture device right it wasn't it was
supposed like it was supposed to
increase your vertical I couldn't jump
but I was telling it really matter it's
supposed to increase your vertical leap
and your quickness and all these things
you know my dad also had the big ball
you remember that yeah big basketball is
a ball that was a few inches bigger than
normal basketball if he could shoot with
the big ball then you could shoot with
the regular ball you know the
interesting thing sidebar my dad is
still in of these devices my dad is a
prolific golfer he plays once a week and
he's probably he's gonna retire soon
he's gonna play all the time anywhere
strengths shoes he has
if you know you're watching TV and you
see a device a golfing device being sold
my dad has that like every single thing
that you can buy every contraption every
driver he has all of it and every time I
talk to him he's like I got the so on so
so and there's just a thing that'll make
you break your wrist and write plays and
so I see that going back and I'm the
same way
you know he's completely jamming the
gimmick he's into the gimmicks he's into
the things can be in compulsive about
that and so am i but your question was
do I resent that I don't because there
were long hours I mean you would have to
wear the strength shoes and jump up on
the Box jump down jump up on the bigger
box jump down jump up on the third big
box jump down I mean this is like it
whenever I came to visit you is like man
it's like going to a like a torture camp
like Guantanamo III honestly can say I
don't resent it I here's what here's
what happened I worked pretty hard a lot
harder than most kids work at their
sport probably and I was good at it you
know I had a lot of success I the
opportunity to play college basketball I
turned it down so we could go to NC
State with the engineers that's kind of
a different story
but the the idea of being taught that no
you have to work hard you have to
practice you have to devote X amount of
hours to this if you're going to be
better than everyone else at you're
gonna be the best yeah because this
isn't just some hobby right this is like
do you want to be the best at this and I
just think that's how it's how my dad
thinks and that's how he taught me to
think and so I think that with the long
story is that we ended up getting and we
started this band the wax paper dogs and
we thought that we were gonna be rock
stars and that immediately took me off
of the basketball track and I was like I
don't want to do this who preceded the
basketball aspirations yeah I was like
you know I'm not gonna be in the NBA I
wasn't that good you know I might go to
like lower level Division one college
and basically just be a basketball
player but I'm not gonna be able to play
music and what is link gonna do because
we wanted to go to the same school and
the blood oath yeah the blood oath the
blood of my dad accepted that and he and
I know that he it led him down a little
because he wanted one of his kids to be
a college athlete I know that for a fact
and I had and my brother was very good
at basketball too and he could have
played at a smaller school too but he
ended up going to Carolina he wanted to
you know go to a good school and get a
get a real degree and so I ended up
doing the kind of the same thing and so
I know that that was a disappointment
but he never let me know it he never
said it he never said anything when I
decided Dale I'm going NC State so no I
don't resent it
he wasn't overbearing it was just he's
and he's an intense individual but I
think I needed that yeah I remember kind
of watching from the silent well
literally watching from the sidelines I
was certainly was no basketball player
but not only that but watching from the
sidelines of this whole drama of are you
gonna be a basketball player and we
didn't talk about this blotto thing when
we're like juniors and seniors in high
school it wasn't like man you can't be a
basketball player because we signed a
blood oath like a couple of years ago we
did talk about it a little bit because
remember we went to that whole phase we
talked about UNC Asheville because I was
being recruited by you and so yeah but I
I remember thinking that I I just could
it's not like I can make an argument to
convince you that you shouldn't be a
basketball player you know but I
remember being nervous about it it was
like well you know we had this kind of
vision for what we were gonna do and it
was being threatened but it was just
something that I couldn't I couldn't
press but I also feel like when we made
the decision to be engineers we also
kind of concurrently made the decision I
think passively that this blood oath
thing was probably just this light we're
gonna be friends forever yeah because I
think that it the practical really
overpowered the dream and we didn't have
a lot of opportunity it was like well
we're not going to film school that
seemed like the only shot that we had at
this I'm not gonna move to Los Angeles
you know I'm not gonna we didn't even
talk about that it wasn't nice Angeles
didn't exist we didn't know
a person a a person who had ever moved
to Los Angeles I had moved from there as
a child but no you didn't know anybody
who moved there to do anything not one
person we never discussed it yeah yeah
it was totally off the radar so I think
we you know yeah and as engineers it was
the type of thing that yeah it was okay
yeah now we're just gonna do this but
we're still friends yeah yeah and I'd
listen I I don't want to I also want to
isolate this conversation to childhood
in high school and I don't well we can
talk about the the career stuff sure
let's move it back a little bit so you
have another question for you and that
question is why did you care about
school because let me premise that with
I cared about school because I was
scared of my dad as we've established
love my dad respecting my dad I was
fearful of my dad because he did not put
up with you know he didn't put up with
bad performance including grades and so
it's just like I was always a straight-a
student set for conduct I had problems
in conduct but I got straight A's in the
subjects and if I made a B it was a it
was a really big deal you can't make it
be in the McLaughlin household that's a
failure right so I carry that all the
way through high school all the way
through college and never made let's see
always made a beat that was the worst
ever did but you did exactly the same
thing actually probably were slightly
definitely a better college student than
I was in a slightly better high school
student why what why did you care I was
just naturally smarter than you no no I
don't know I think I just felt like and
it wasn't this or if you're gonna do
something you got to do it to the best
of your ability it wasn't
an external value that I was taught but
I think it and I don't know that it but
on the other team I don't know that it
was kind of a people-pleasing thing but
it was like well K if I mean I mean I'm
a student I'm supposed to do the best
that I can
it was just but if you had a brought
home a see just an approach there wasn't
your mom what your mom would have been
disappointed but that would be the end
of it no my mom was not a disciplinarian
and in and he's in anyway really
I mean I was her only child you know and
the only child she would ever have I
think that she had that sense so yeah
you know I was the baby it was there was
not a lot of discipline going on or so
she was not driving me to do it but it
was something that I just always had
that and I don't think it's a good thing
by the way that I just felt like whoa
okay I'm just supposed to I just I have
to be good at this and I so I don't I
don't even think I know I think now
there's what were you scared of though
because I wasn't scared of anything well
I would maybe just feeling like a
failure it's like if you don't do your
best you just feel like well I just kind
of like why if I'm gonna do this I have
to have to really try I wasn't trying to
please anybody I don't know what do you
think well I got yeah but theory no I
don't I just it and I and it hit me
recently cuz then cuz I know exactly why
I never slacked off right there was my
parents both both my mom and my dad they
just instilled this fear my mom used to
say all the time like even as we were
going off to get ready to go to college
she was like now you've gotten by with
straight A's in high school just because
you're smart but when you go to college
everybody's smart and you're really
going to work so I remember that first
semester me and you room together and we
just studied our freshman year we just
study held it all the time
you know 4.0 freshman year and at a
certain point you realize that you
didn't care that much and it didn't
matter so sophomore year
I never had that realization like you'd
be out you and Greg our roommate you be
out playing video games and I would be
studying for like four more hours
because just a blind sense of obligation
to well if you started you have to
finish it and you have to do as good as
you can if you don't do the best that
you can do you're robbing yourself of
something
I mean maybe my Nana kind of taught me
that if you're gonna mow grass don't
just don't just make sure all the grass
is cut make sure it's cut the best it
can be cut because I cut all her her
neighbors yards and that she said don't
half-ass anything the only time I heard
my Nana cuss as a kid was when she told
me that don't half-ass the grass don't
have asked the grass is the only time
ever to cuss as a kid now she's just you
know she's found me no no she doesn't
care I neither do I but I don't know
that it she instilled instill that I
think it I think it was I don't know I
don't know it was just I just if I can't
do it I have to do it I'm gonna be a
failure if I don't mmm no I didn't hit
me into like by college by college it
was a I got to make the best grades
because that that links directly to
getting a good job and I've always been
anxious about money I don't think money
was related to grades at a young age
though hmm I should I should give you
another question you should wasn't it
weird watching horror movies with your
mom I know that as a kid she would like
put on Hellraiser and watch it with you
but if you were and you've kind of
talked about it isn't this funny and
like you come from this like really
conservative family and but in this
particular area it and that was kind of
the joke that your mom literally when
you were in middle school watched hell
raise it with you she would go and rent
a video videos all the time and then you
you watch horror movies with her yeah
and after that Texas Chainsaw Massacre
I've III wouldn't watch a horror movie
for until I graduated from college I
think the deal with my mom is that she
took the the most motion picture
associations
guidelines very very very literally it
said parental guidance you know so she
guided you in front of the television
with her yeah yeah as long as she was
there he's like razors not PG do notice
are it's restricted
it says parents strongly cautioned it
says you know children not permitted
without their parents but that means you
are permitted with your parents age were
you when you saw Hellraiser with your
mom
middle school man and what was that
experience like because of some because
for me that would have been the worst
thing ever
I loved it then I love it now my mom my
mom is this you know my mom she's the
sweetest lady she is the she is first of
all she's the sweetest lady but she's
she's still very conservative and but
she has this part of her which is dark
side no no she likes that kind of thing
and she she called me she tell her she
texted me a couple months ago whenever
this movie was in the theater and she
was like I just watched insidious two in
a theater all by myself
so you know she she's this this meat not
me
not only meaning she didn't have a date
like you're your dad didn't go well my
mom goes to movies bar so there was no
one else in the Thea was the only one
and then and she said something like it
was so scary but so and I'm totally
relate to that she instilled that when
we invited all of our friends over here
for my birthday to watch the conjuring
well well that's the point you want you
how to get together for your birthday
and that was the idea it was to get a
bunch of grown men together and the
scare the crap out of them and watched
them act like little children and that's
what they did it was embarrassing I was
embarrassed for half of those guys now I
was scared out of my mind but I loved it
I don't know it's just that we like
thrills like that in my family and my
mom has just always been like that was
it weird no it was awesome
did it affect me negatively I don't know
I still liked horror movies but I turned
out okay I went to my dad's I had
visitation every other weekend and our
in
[Music]
he pull it I remember he rented leave
the weapon too which has a sex scene in
it and I guess by the time the sex scene
came on and I was like in third grade or
something and he didn't you know as I
just let it roll
regular speed regulus I watched a lot of
sex scenes and fast forward we'd hear a
lot of really quick thrusting yeah oh
gosh because that's horror movies
there's got to be the sexy lethal weapon
to I mean it was a great movie but
there's a sex scene that I wouldn't
recommend for any of my kids or a third
grader yeah my mom never let the sex
scenes just live in their regular pace
that wasn't that wasn't wrong but fast
yeah you had to get through it so she
amino Europe so you're restricted me
somewhat your performance expectations
now in marriage our yard to be very
quick about I brought a weird
perspectives into my marriage having
seen only fast forward sex my entire
life
Wow yeah it's great I was so embarrassed
with that I remember um we didn't
discuss I didn't tell my mom now
speaking of guilty pleasures like horror
movies you know I I'm in the same boat
but I feel like you had a special
passion for it gangster rap tell me
about your obsession with gangster rap
and how that came about now one of our
first videos on a YouTube channel was
white boys visit Compton which was a
podcast first you'll see that it says
rhett and Link cast and we really saw in
i2z and we started put them on YouTube
that video we give a little bit of this
story actually I haven't seen it and so
long I don't remember but the the start
of my love for rap music was your
brother Cole mm-hmm
Cole was it was so cool to go to your
house because not only did we get to
hang out we were friends but a guy who
is four years older three three years
older was there okay this guy's
we're in eighth grade he's a junior in
high school man yeah and he would try to
pin me against you like not physically
but like I remember that he would say
okay you'd say I got the new a guy I got
the new DJ Jazzy Jeff tape anybody got
the new young MC tape and this is this
is way back in the day but and he said
which link which one do you like better
yeah well I gotta pick whoever like Oh
Cole likes better because he's older and
he's cooler you didn't think he was cool
he was a jerk
you guys getting you'll get in fights
and I would just laugh and laugh and
laugh he would make you angry
oh so mad he would make you angry in
front of me just to embarrass you oh
yeah and then you got it I took the bait
every time and you got mad at one time
and you started chasing him he ran in
his room and slammed the door and you
threw your speed stick deodorant against
the door and it went everywhere like a
fire do you know what he was saying at
that moment he was saying that I liked
Melissa Hood Oh remember that Melissa
hood she lived in the neighborhood oh
yeah and I wrong with liking Melissa huh
I didn't like her though I mean to the
up to this day I'll throw deodorant at
you if you tell me that I like to
Melissa no but he just would start it
and he would any kept pushing and
pushing and pushing it and ever were you
the two of you ran actually I can
vividly remember this I had a good arm
and you got you ran into his room and I
came to the top of the steps and I heard
speed stick deodorant and I threw it it
would have hit him between the eyeballs
he didn't slam the door he slammed the
door and it just blew up all over white
white everywhere dust particles
everywhere I was so mad but he liked
gangsta rap feisty in there and it was
so off limits to listen to this stuff
that's another thing my mom let us watch
horror movies with her but she did not
know she was ignorant about the gangsta
rap she did not know what was being
rapped about in my brother's room and I
felt like it was so cool to come to your
house and I felt like I was friends with
a high schooler I mean I wasn't but I
had that
illusion because if I took his side you
would be angry and I would spin cool it
was great and this music was everyone
always thinks that things have gotten
worse everyone thinks that things get
you know there's moral degradation as
time goes it has not that's not the case
okay
people have always been bad people have
always been good now the music has not
gotten any worse I mean maybe there's a
little bit more mainstream except
because I mean NW was very misogynistic
and it was very I mean and it was very
brutal I mean talking about over-the-top
gang gang violence but also I mean she
was just it was out of the war songs
where they were explicitly sexual
misogynistic it was uh I mean there were
a couple of songs that Cole felt so bad
about that he he taped over them he had
a little bit of a contract and the first
CD I ever saw was one a Cole bought of a
rap of like Gang Starr and I was like
this is so cool one day I'll have a CD
player
he didn't out to his credit he did not
have 2 Live Crew yeah he knew there was
a line somewhere and if it was just like
ok 2 Live Crew is just rapping about sex
that's that's it
so he's like ok you know I'm not I'm not
gonna do that but we can we can stick
with the other stuff we haven't gotten
to any Twitter questions maybe we should
move a little faster for these last
month's Random TV USA wanted me to ask
you who was your best friend before link
I don't know the answer to this actually
I never anybody in California that's a
really good question I can honestly not
tell you the first name of any one I'm
from California I was three four and
five and we lived there I'm sure that my
mom could help me think of this but no
no nobody do you remember I mean I grew
up in it my first best friend was Brad
this guy who I went to preschool with
for years and we like would dig holes in
driveway of horses listener
[Music]
can't McDonald Brad McDonald so we were
like preschool buddies it was just two
of us
Loretta kept us she's like four foot
three inches tall woman yeah and then
kindergarten Matthew ends or who we were
friends with all through high school
yeah was I thought he was the coolest
guy because he could run almost as fast
as Randolph Clegg who was a black guy
and you weren't friends with black
people when I was in kindergarten I'm
just you know that's just the way it was
so Randolph was the fastest guy I wanted
him to be my best friend but he was
black so Matthew the the fastest white
guy had to be my best you know and I
want to clarify because I think that
there's a lot of people who don't come
from the same area in the same time that
we came from and it was a time when yeah
save me if I've said anything it went oh
I want to clarify that we come from a
place where there was you know systemic
racism and it was ugly it but it wasn't
open you know by the time it was
1983-1984 no one was saying any we
didn't hear people say racist things
directly to people we didn't hear white
people talk directly to black people in
a racist way hardly ever but they also
didn't talk to each other and you but
but white people would talk negatively
about about black people and vice versa
within their own groups and then you
were friends with with people of other
races and really where we come from it
was just white and black people that was
it there were really very few Asian
people who are if you expand people but
you didn't hang out and you weren't real
friends you didn't go to each other's
homes and that kind of thing and it was
just the way it was and we didn't know
we didn't know any difference so I'm
just clarifying there wasn't like thank
you for rescuing me I was I was no more
racist than anyone else at the time but
I was I was brought up in that and so I
felt like okay the coolest people are
the people who can run the fastest
because in recess every day they we
would have like a student organized race
at foot races the fastest people were
the coolest people I was nowhere near
the fastest so I just wanted to be
friends with the fastest person or the
fastest white person because that was
that was mandatory option yeah Matthew
and Sue and then it was a first grade
when the next year
when we met so I had a couple of best
friends now Matthew Enzo his best friend
was jr. I can't remember his last name
right now the blond kid so I knew that
it was not reciprocated I was not his
best friend did he give it back I was
very frustrated and and then when you
know we were I mean I would I don't know
that we were immediately best friends we
were we were very close friends but I
don't know if you'd apply that label
until that we were best friends worried
really I would say that we were as good
of friends as I had yeah at the time all
through elementary school but I had
these these these friends that I mean
really first and second grade it was
kind of like you know I had you and Tate
Maddox and Michael Juby paint Maddox at
the time I mean he was kind of a tool I
mean he wore Doc head shorts with the
shirt his shirt tucked in but with
nobody else did but we thought that was
super cool what I did
he always had a girlfriend yeah but then
third grade third grade is when Ben
Greenwood moved into town and Ben became
you know we me and you and him were as
they were and there were probably times
I think this relates to Lexie pose
question from Twitter she says was there
ever a point when you guys were kids
that you thought your friendship might
be over hmm
like a fight no but in terms of am I am
I not a my second best friend now yes so
two-part question the first one
there was definitely a time in which I
thought that Ben was my best friend I'd
say like fourth fifth grade we lived
closer together we spent more time
together the three of us were together
almost all the time but then there was
also a year in there fourth grade and
fifth grade which we were in different
classes right so Hamm was in my class
and I would I would go over and hang out
with you guys at Ben's house or your
house and you would you would report to
me all the things you had done over the
past two weeks when I wasn't hanging out
with you we found this weed that is
hollow in the middle and we've decided
to smoke it and we're calling it the big
George now
they did they did not put anything in it
it was just like just an actual weed it
wasn't weed it wasn't an wheat oh we
yeah and you would let it on fire and
you simulated smoking it like a
cigarette you had no clue what you were
doing you didn't even know what
marijuana was service or it was horrible
good but it was a weed and you caught it
the big George and you would build lean
twos and Ben had all these ideas and I
remember feeling threatened then oh yeah
yeah they're best friends I'm on the
fringe I live across town you lived
across town and you were in a different
class but I never thought that a social
class like a like a literally a
different teacher at a lower class you
live in a smaller house no yeah
different teacher and I don't know how
they do it in eighth grade
you know sixth seventh eighth grade
these days but the way we did it is you
were in the same class all day well no
it's for sixth grade but starting
seventh eighth grade we did have
different classes different teachers at
this point in the I'm just gonna like
come back to the reality of the year
biscuit here and at this point I'm
thinking all of a sudden we've lost ours
I feel like I've lost myself in our past
and I have no clue how this feels to
anyone listening like I feel like Oh
rattling come back to us you let me
nothing about your past but that's why
it's experimental I mean this is why we
this is why we tried it is this it I
have this is we want to know how you
feel about it and if you want us to
continue to do this kind of thing but
let me answer the second part of the
question okay was there a point when you
were kids that you thought that your
friendship might be over I would say
that there were Titan you've relayed
this to me before which i think is also
a question that you might have for me
about girls I have a question for you
about girls I do yeah
and that is that I had I was very
obsessive about women and fix would go
from one girl to the next fixated on a
girl whether she reciprocated yeah so
what's your question cuz I want to I
don't want to go too far well so what
might it's not really a question I'm
saying that there were times in which
because of a girl friends oh into a girl
that I've kind of forgot about you for
all that I mean I certainly happened but
I didn't feel threatened as a best
friend because it wasn't
friend it was a girlfriend that's a
different thing I kind of feel like I
definitely had the question I wanted to
ask you why did you think why do you
think you were so obsessive about girls
I almost don't want to ask it now
because I feel like when we want to keep
the podcast to a certain length that I
think there's some good stuff to unpack
if we decide this is a good thing we can
wait for that we can do the relational
the girl stuff there cuz there's a lot
of girls stole a lot of really good girl
stuff I mean you know sharing first
girlfriend sharing first kiss
I like your obsession with girls and my
fear of girls I think they call it
teaser link let's make that another
podcast not that we have to end it right
now I'm trying to see if I'm looking
through these Twitter questions to see
if there's another one I feel like this
is kind of part they're like couples
therapy like what's happening here maybe
a little bit of that are you fit do you
feel like you're getting an appreciation
of our friendship I it's so easy to lose
sight of how long we've been friends cuz
you just get into the grind of what are
we going to accomplish or what do we
have to do this week or this monster
well are we going no I think I am
gaining appreciate appreciation of it
final I do think it is a little bit like
not that I didn't appreciate it I think
it is a little bit like counseling
without without a mediator I do good
unless you call the mythical beasts who
are listening that you're biscuit ears
the mediator which is a weird way to
thing well I sense their presence but I
do I think this is a good question to
close with and this is a question that
we used as a teaser over and over again
on good mythical morning season 3 I
guess it was when we would on our
question episodes we would say did you
do this do you that and did you ever
have you ever punched each other in the
face and we never answer the question
did somebody ask us so deal biz on
Twitter who's followed us for a while
says have you ever punched each other in
the face hashtag throwbackthursday he's
been a fan for awhile so he knows that
this is something that we used all the
time as a teaser on good mythical
morning so let's just close by answering
that question have we ever punched each
other in the face no we haven't
okay so that's it we have it but but I
will say I have we have you ever reared
back your fist at me I mean no you you
were throwing the deodorant at me and
Cole
cuz Cole was involved and I think that's
the point I wanted to make and that is
as children as children I don't think we
were even ever even close to being on
the verge of a physical altercation with
one another and I and I think that
here's my theory okay no I have a theory
and and but I think that now in current
you know our friendship is much deeper
much more complex stronger than it than
it was when we were 12 years old but the
nature of our you know the nature of our
friendship and the nature of our
business the nature of this being in
this creative endeavor together there
are times when we get very mad at one
another and there are a couple of times
we've gotten really mad at each other
I'd say in it probably ten times in the
past ten years where it's crossed my
mind that we might be about to get into
a fistfight like we might be a like that
might happen like really yeah we've been
so mad at each other that it's crossed
my mind that like it wouldn't be totally
out of the question right now if one of
us punched the other but is it but are
you really thinking it wouldn't be out
of the question if link punched me at
this moment is that really what you
think yeah you cuz I feel as you I don't
feel like you get madder than I do
right I feel like you think I would
never punch him but sometimes I just
don't know he just might don't loose
cannon on me yeah yeah I'm like he's a
lot madder than I then I thought that he
was right now and I'm what I'm gonna say
is that when you were a child before you
became a man that never happened like
you never had that in you you never had
this you never had this like I might
punch you right now I'm so mad I'm gonna
punch you you never had that that was
something that like began to emerge like
after college I think as a kid I
remember getting so angry at certain
things that my mom floated the idea that
what if he what if you got a pillow that
when you got angry you would punch it
like I remember that and not very
unsatisfying I think that was going into
like dealing with puberty but I do
remember her making that suggest almost
you know hormones going crazy puberty
going nuts no pun intended but I I
actually tried it I went to my room and
I punched my bed and I don't remember it
helping but it but it didn't play out in
in our friendship we didn't really fight
I don't think we argued no I mean what
was there to argue about I mean there's
it we got stuff to argue about every 30
minutes now because we're creating
things in there right you you have
creation requires opinions and we're not
always going to share the same
perspective on things well I think we've
learned to it except that now that we
couldn't do a better job of this but in
general that create the creative process
there for us there's there's a
give-and-take and there's a like let's
throw this idea back and forth sometimes
like throw it pretty hard back and forth
until it shakes out into what it should
be well I also think that's another
conversation is the whole creative
process the fact that there is a lot of
conflict involved in it so nobody sees
three special episodes if you kill this
one then we've got the girl episode and
then we've got the creative process
unless this is a fail I mean I'm I'm
opening right I'm open to that maybe it
was but I think it was good for us but
there's no one else hears this I think
it was good for us to have some
perspective on our on our friendship
that though this one's going out oh oh
yeah this one's going out are you gonna
tell him that we that we recorded in a
one earlier that never went out is that
what you're implying
because I think I just accidentally told
them yeah yeah that we already tried
this and it didn't work we were we tried
this and it was a totally different
format we didn't like the way it turned
out okay there we admitted it maybe
it'll be like on some secret channel at
some point yeah it'll be yeah one day
we'll exploit it when we can make it a
cellar for seller for a few dollars but
from a website created by our sponsor of
this episode squarespace.com well you
did you're doing that I want it okay I
wanted to transition to an outro and
then I thought about our sponsor again
and so I'm gonna make it natural and
then you screwed it up okay I'll go
there with you make your own website
it's easy it's gonna look good square
Squarespace don't go to space square com
yeah good as well actually I don't think
it exists so you can go to Squarespace
calm they'll help you set up a domain
for space square calm and that can be
your website that's confusing
it could be anything you want it to be
and just remember you get a free trial
without a credit card but then if you
decide to do it you get 10% off if you
use the code that helps us R and L and
we are you still doing the plug no no
I'm moving on okay you're moving back to
like we were in this like heartfelt
moment of this and then you're like in
the middle that's the story of our lives
yeah it is men hey listen I got you know
we got to pay for this Wow I mean that
that is so pristinely where we are
professionally and personally
it's it's just mashed it's all mashed
together listen I would sponsor my face
if I could I could I'm just kidding man
yeah okay I did sponsor my hair though
if somebody would buy your face you
would yeah I mean I wouldn't tattoo it
this is maybe like a like a shaving
company or something all of a sudden
we've gone from from heartfelt
introspection to blatant
commercialization let's go back no no we
don't have to go back to crazy town
where you talk about butt
sponsoring your face like your face is a
your face is a show it could be a note
your face or and a billboard you you
mean sell your face with ad space that's
what you know yeah you mean people will
do this by the way you talk at me like
I'm crazy but you know and we've got
this Google glass thing is happening
well that's gonna keep happening and
then they're gonna start looking cool
and then there's gonna be a button that
you press on the side of them and a
message comes up on your glasses for
other people
billboard face yeah yeah and it'll be
like Squarespace where we'll be and one
who blends and space will be in the
other lens or if you if you buy a URL
then space square if you're selling
stuff or if you're selling squares in
space you can probably a button switch
them and you if well and what I'm saying
is if I believe in the brand and it'll
help us keep doing what we're doing
I'll do it you'll I'll do it you'll put
it on glass I'll put it on anything
I will not permanently tattoo it to my
body I will only do that with my wife's
name which I did and you also did for
the right brand I would tattoo my other
butt cheek with the brand but I would do
it smaller than my wife's name or I
would compass I would make my wife's
name bigger because that would not fly
at home when I drop trou and next time
and it's like what what's the price tag
on that black and decker is just as big
as my what's the price what seriously
what's the price tag for a butt - well I
can't answer that because I've answered
that it gives people a window into how
much we get for sponsorship anyway I'm
not comfortable yo yeah we can't
disclose that I'm not comfortable giving
people any point of reference for how
much money we don't make I won't say I
won't say how much I'm willing to get
paid but I will throw it out there that
if you want my butt cheek I'm willing to
get that sponsored - no one will see it
do you realize the irony in this no no
but wait how about your butt cheek
nobody sees it well my wife does well
I'm gonna advertise to your wife my wife
will buy whatever it is that's being
advertised on my butt and since when is
she looked at your butt I'm done every
morning
no she I sleep in the nude you think I
was leaving the nude and why is this
happen and we have a mirror and
yes I mean us discussing a one-hole half
of our bedroom wall is a mirror so if
she doesn't see when I get up she's
easing when I turn around can can we put
this vehicle in Reverse you asked about
what it would take what the
effectiveness would be of me getting my
butt tattooed with a sponsor black you
mentioned Black & Decker I don't know if
they're yeah you put black on your cheek
and I put and Decker on mine oh you can
just put Decker we can we can hold the
ampersand between us okay what is this
about tattooing on butt cheeks that is
something that comes out of your psyche
because we did it because you did it
yeah I saw it yeah I saw it
actually yesterday I don't see it often
but every once I'm like oh yeah I do
have a tattoo you said my wife's name
and it's on my butt that's cool yes I
mean I don't regret it there's never a
day that goes by that I regret it it's
unlike you know a face tattoo or an egg
tattoo
this is a butt tattoo this is a
different ball I've never regretted it
either yeah I would
I've never thought about adding to it
either though or adding any time I
thought about getting it underlined for
Valentine's Day okay cuz it's minimal
investment yes like it's just a lot what
did you give me for Valentine's Day I
got you this line I underlined your name
so it's like every year then there's an
expectation that next year I put it in
quotes no no that's that's condescending
it's like you know I'm like mom I'm
using it like they use it on billboards
and stuff that they don't understand
they use quotes for emphasis I'm using
it in that colloquial sense no I think
that the expectation would be okay you
underlined again did you double unders
you keep underlining it and then it
would just it could become like all of a
sudden it's on a pedestal
I could probably underline it for the
rest of our marriage if the lines are
small enough like I think it should be
like a pedestal yeah it's just a little
line that if we stay missing the most of
you I've had all week by the way if we
stay married long enough there's gonna
the
is gonna be a petal still going down my
right leg it holds up your name on my
bunch like what is that tattoo well it
kinda it leads to my wife's name I'm
about to yeah or you could you could do
like puffy letters you can i mean it's
it's like cursive i don't think you
could do that at this point without
screwing it up but I can put a drop
shower shadow on it this year I gave you
a drop shadow it's like I mean there's
something to that because there's a chat
there's a creative challenge that I that
resonates with me that every Valentine's
Day what do you well you didn't
underline you did you can't make it
italics
what's this no one person yeah once it's
done you can't you can drop shadow it
you can quote it you can underline it I
think we should end this I mean I
balloon around I don't I mean I don't
you know I'm not gonna say I don't trust
Alex or Stevie in order to make the
editorial decision but I'm saying I
think I want to easy letdown I think we
we just took that tattoo as far as we
could and and now we can just say that
you know again want to remind you a
couple of things number one if you liked
this let us know number two it helps us
a lot when you go to iTunes and you rate
our podcast you leave a review have you
ever seen those reviews we're not
reviews tattoos you said review where
they like make a whole arm sleeve
totally ink or like the guy for Rage
Against the Machine his whole left PEC
is ink like solid ink it's when they
mess up it up they just make it totally
well yeah I could make everything on my
right butt cheek total ink except for
pink using Butchie
except for her name so it would be like
a it'll be like a dark room with a
spotlight on her name is what it would
be try that see how that feels
well it's gonna take time because I'm
gonna do it by underlining her name I'm
a circle ur name every year you squealed
so much when that happened I can't
imagine you getting all butt cheek done
[Music]
[Music]